ok bon ben c'est par téléphone que
l'intersyndicale de general electric a
appris la nouvelle en début d'après midi
le tribunal de grande instance a suivi
les arguments des avocats de la
direction et se déclare incompétent
l'intersyndicale demandait la suspension
du plan social elle est déboutée
les élus sont déçus mais pas abattus
c'est que c'est un long chemin mais on
ne fera une économie sur rien et si on
doit à ressaisir je veux dire une
instance compétente ou s'il est jugé
plus compétente et de on va mener aussi
de bien tout le travail politique y
compris sur l'état parce que de toute
façon l'idée c'est d'amener macron
autour de la table élus représentants du
personnel et leurs avocats décideront
dans les jours à venir s'ils font appel
de cette décision
l'autre option est de solliciter le
tribunal administratif avec là aussi
beaucoup d'incertitudes quant aux
résultats
la forte mobilisation dans les rues de
belfort le 22 juin le soutien des élus
locaux
autant d'éléments qui poussent les
salariés à continuer leur lutte contre
le plan social
on a beaucoup de raisons d'y croire le
marché de la turbine à gaz
aujourd'hui tout le monde s'accorde à
dire qu'une il a de l'avenir
il va rebondir dans les années à venir
pour une raison très simple c'est que
c'est la seule technologie en capacité
d'accompagner le déploiement des
énergies renouvelables en milieu d'après
midi la direction de gee a publié un
bref communiqué nous espérons que nos
instances représentatives du personnel
vont tirer les conclusions de cette
décision de justice pour initier les
discussions et la négociation sur le
projet de réorganisation
car les élus refusent de négocier le
plan social ils n'ont pas l'intention de
s'asseoir à la table des négociations à
partir de jeudi ils seront aux
eurockéennes pour sensibiliser les
festivaliers et faire signer la pétition
de soutien aux salariés